tu veux quoi en tchèque
mais tu peux aller poser tes chaussures
l état soit bonjour si monde tu veux
quoi un calme à chacun sa façon de dire
bonjour
après cette jolie entrée en matière les
enfants abordent le coeur du sujet les
émotions à pour quelles raisons est ce
que tu veux nous l'expliqué oui à super
alors on t'écoute et les émotions les
siennes celles des autres comment les
dire comment les entendre en un mot
comment communiquer en y mettant des
formes plutôt que des coûts ou des mots
blessants
en fait on constate depuis de nombreuses
années que les élèves ne met plus de
filtres dans leur façon de s'appréhender
et de se parler et souvent ils passent
directement à des actes assez violent
physique ou par les mots donc du coup on
avait vraiment envie de développer cette
approche autour de la communication pour
leur apprendre justement à s'exprimer et
à trouver des solutions en cas de
désaccord et qu'est ce que tu fais voilà
ça c'est dur c'est brammo jade très
belles situations ils peuvent parler des
situations qu'ils ont vécues sans se
mettre acteurs eux c'est la petite
peluche qui parle et ça c'est très
important pour qu'ils puissent délivre
enfin ce délibéré et délivrer des
messages qu'ils ont vidés livrés au fur
et à mesure des 10 séances avec l'aide
de ses précieuses peluche
les enfants découvrent et explore à leur
rythme cet univers si compliqué des
relations et dans cet univers les mots
ont toute leur importance
qu'est ce qu'on lui fait à ce petit
lézard aux
canal tu crois ouais ok donc tu vas leur
réponds non pas récompensés et et
réconfort voilà super et comporte qu'est
ce que ça veut dire réconforter ça veut
dire que par exemple vincent roca l'un à
l'autre et très bien ça ça valait bien
plus les enfants connaîtront du
vocabulaire sur les émotions et pluies
seront à même de pouvoir décrire ce
qu'ils ressentent donc c'est très très
important de le ramener le maximum
d'expérience et de vocabulaire une école
plus paisible pour de meilleur
apprentissage voilà l'objectif des
mousquetaires du bonheur un projet
pilote qui à l'évidence mérite d'être
largement étendue